oh my god this isn't the hottest one so
I'm so so far I have a sensitive mouth
Sean I'm not good at this
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot once it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're celebrating Thanksgiving the
best way we know how and that's with
Brad Leone
he's the Test Kitchen manager turned
star and host of it's alive with Brad
and it's alive going places go check
those out on bone Appetit youtuber
streaming channels but first a very
special Thanksgiving feast with the
wings of death Brad Leone welcome to the
Sean thank you the wings of death huh
yes yeah I'm excited man you know I had
a little taste of a couple of your
sauces you know it must been what a
couple years ago has yeah solid two
three years ago and they were pretty
unenjoyable
[Music]
alright so we just do this uh-huh I
realize curse big time let it fly nice
quality chicken so it's a real
Thanksgiving miracle that this bald man
and a guy named Brad who talks about
fermentation or somehow eating hot wings
to an Internet audience of millions
especially when you think about how it
all started
do you remember the day that you went
from dishwasher to TV host
it was more of a progressive build I
mean when I started there was there
really wasn't a video presence it was if
anything it was like a couple recipe
real short format hands and pans as we
used to call them like overhead shot
that I'm doing things in my hands were
done clean swaps yadda yadda boring not
to me not cooking you know so we started
to experiment with other formats you
know more personality driven actual
human conversations and whatnot and then
it's alive which you know on paper
probably shouldn't have happened
say oh but uh same no I always think
about that I always think about that how
we were like two guys that against all
odds and in such a bizarre way kind of
survived that pivot to video which was
like such a massacre for like the rest
of new media but somehow bread is Shawn
me put it that way it sounds great Shawn
I wanted to keep that human element of
cooking the mistakes that you know the
having fun with it
learning you know because a lot of
people are gonna make mistakes too even
when I'm doing things right things
happen wrong
I was really I'm glad these are chicken
wings
you know this whole Thanksgiving special
I was like oh Christ he's gonna pull out
for a big turkey legs or turkey wings
you know the world is Thanksgiving
special we got some boards on the tab
you know but the best for me and then we
have some some table decor you nailed it
bud and I see you got some milk to her
[Music]
nice many heat I want to take a wing to
talk about fermentation and I mean this
as a compliment because it's really
amazing how you've taken this niche
extremely specialized topic and made it
one of the most popular shows in the
zeitgeist how would you explain food
fermentation in terms that even a simple
chicken wing talk show host can
understand so it's basically just
controlled raw it's what people did
before we had refrigeration essentially
things are starting to break down
through different whether it be yeast
bacteria funguses or a combination of
all of them working together to break
things down and a byproduct of that is a
lot of healthy probiotic benefits for us
which are we're gonna need Shawn we're
gonna need them bad have you ever
forgotten to burp what do they call burp
check Ajay a man we've had some
explosions and then had like a bottle of
kimchi blow up in your hand or anything
oh yeah
back before I knew about different
grades of quality and bottles for
withholding pressure from the inside I
was using what they call in the industry
ornamental bottles like the pop top ones
you get a little restaurant they get
rewarded in it so I was making the
lambrusco and I I pulled it off the
grapes and I was looking good so I
wanted to do a secondary fermentation in
the bottle to produce carbonation I was
like a Chrismukkah he's what he's a
senior I don't know what the hell is
title is but he's the food at her that
bone Appetit
I work to him for years he's great he's
standing next to me and I'm looking at
it and I go I don't think it worked
Chris I don't think I don't think it
carbonated I say I'm just gonna open it
[ __ ] it and as soon as I you know those
little pop toppy things yeah soon as I
like went to even like push it a little
bit I'm talking like 12-gauge shotgun
and this glass turned into sand I had
little micro cuts on my face
Chris was [ __ ] shaking he didn't talk
for like two weeks and I mean there was
there was basement brusque on the
ceiling on the floor on my face ever I
literally I'm luckily all jokes aside I
mean it's funny as hell now but lucky
someone catch you gonna shock me I
could've been it could have been a real
bad day well I'm thankful on this
Thanksgiving that it didn't go down like
that let's be thankful I didn't me or
Chris Morocco did not
and that is such a lovely segue to the
next wing I love this we gonna go on
blind let's see all right Brad we have a
little surprise for you here because you
can't have a Thanksgiving feast and not
invite over some guests so earlier this
week we reached out to some of your
comrades in the Test Kitchen so here
they are the bone Appetit Test Kitchen
Avengers grilling Brad on Thanksgiving
and at first up is guess who I don't
know
deputy food editor Chris Morocco Oh son
of a [ __ ] hey Brad how you doing buddy
your old pal Chris Crocker from the Bon
Appetit Test Kitchen case your eyes are
too full of tears see who it is
have you ever been in a helicopter and
if so why I don't talk to my lawyer
helicopter ride at one time but it
wasn't like for fun it was I got um I
was hit by a car
whoa so you had to take like the ride to
the hospital I got that it wasn't free
it was like 30 grand
but yeah me and my friend we were we
were it was our fault we were on an ATV
or Perry mug no if you're listening
crazy bastard I'm flying around I don't
know I was 18 or something you know and
and we took this one turn on the inside
and we looked we didn't see any cars
coming but as soon as we came around
that turn Mary in the blind spot Toyota
camera boom a head-on going about 40 and
poor girls driving she was like she just
got her license like two days yeah
they're not really looking for an ATV to
turn the club no you know [ __ ] and
this girl like she was shaking her she
didn't drive for like two years I should
have [ __ ] good therapy or something I
made that up but it probably would
happen alright now we'll take a visit
from Claire oh half's our self-esteem
she has to say hey Claire in the Test
Kitchen apocalypse for being invaded by
zombies what piece of equipment do you
take from the Test Kitchen as a weapon
and why oh yeah and it bonus points that
is more creative than just a knife which
I believe you've chosen before I would
get the largest container to carry water
in
because you know I Dom bees I mean
unless you're talking about some like 40
days 40 what's that one called with the
[ __ ] scary zombies with a running 28
days later 28 days later like that kind
of [ __ ] we're in trouble just kill
yourself alright you're not beating
those [ __ ] not with something out of
the test kitchen at least I mean what
she said not a knife when I'm one of my
one of my [ __ ] grabbing a bag of
coffee and an onion like what are we
doing packing hide for a bunch of days I
think I can outrun a bunch of them
stupid zombies get out of this stupid
City swim across the river get the
jersey and [ __ ] like head to Duluth
or something you know and then water you
need quick man people get ugly real
quick
people start killing people [ __ ] right
yeah pop everybody knows Tommy's right
what the hell do people get weird so I
would try to get water and get the hell
out of Dodge alright we have two more
visitors here Oh two more guests at the
table here alright up next we have
senior food editor Molly what will your
last meal on planet earth be what are
you eating what are you drinking and
who's cooking it for you I don't know
man you know maybe something real simple
it's gave me a real nice perfect tomato
and some [ __ ] salt and olive oil just
get it over it let's just take the big
map all right one more for ya before you
kill me yeah alright from your nemesis
Alex Delaney hey Brad Alex Elena here I
have a question for you [ __ ] marry kill
Sylvester Stallone Arnold Schwarzenegger
jean-claude Van Damme let's hear it Brad
you look a little sweaty over there
oh yeah but I'm talking to my butt I
think I believe in you even though the
internet seems to think that we hate
each other yeah your friend I'm here to
support my friend I guess uh I don't
even feel very good answering this ya
know yeah you know it's not easy for me
either I guess like the first sentence
is just it's kind of funny I guess I'd
[ __ ] Sean call it Van Damme right he was
like handsome and [ __ ] cool and he
can like stretch really good splits and
[ __ ] right just between those three
I see where we go Arnold maybe Mary
right yeah sure
and then what am I left with that means
you gotta go Sylvester Stallone yeah
cool leave I just said I've on the [ __ ]
jean-claude Van Damme John if you're
listening I'm ready
alright see some [ __ ] wings
[Music]
okay so you grew up in Sussex County a
part of New Jersey Toya that you
describe as being better known for its
lush forests than it's a fist pumping
were you down the road from that
Mountain Creek ski resort oh yeah is
that on the bark back you do that that's
what I was gonna say isn't that the
location of action Park oh yeah
action park closed on kids since 93 then
yeah yeah yeah did you did you ever
visit oh yeah what yeah come on small
town so action park for the people who
don't know is like this infamous theme
park but you just have like 50
mile-per-hour go-karts and like kids
bastard a man they had all kinds of no
regulation [ __ ] they didn't care what
stands out I have never talked to
anybody who's a I don't know if this is
true but I think it is oh jeez here we
go so there is this they used to have
this like um you know like the tube
waterslides tube they had one that did
it was a loop a full loop and apparently
an overweight kid got stuck in it and
died whoa
and another one they had you know those
real straight slides better I can't
prove who funds
someone [ __ ] out a couple people in
[ __ ] flew off them there was another
little ski resort that was small they're
a little more mom pop called Hidden
Valley so out there anymore
Jesus Christ and yeah yeah man that
place is this place is legit still there
you should go check it out hey yeah well
I'll get the UH maybe I can get like an
employee discount hookup over absolutely
not
just tell them you've never met me and
maybe they'll let you
it's not to get wicked huh oh look at
all that sauce on you dick oh yeah
hi Brad we have a recurrence segment on
our show called explain that Graham
where you do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram poll interesting oils that
need more context oh yeah all right I
know that here I know that you're big
into our tripping balls I almost never
there 30 yards I was about to ask what
is your target distance and why do you
love archery so much that's very
therapeutic it's just you it's technique
it's thought it's breathing and twenty
eight and a half yards is the farthest I
can go in my backyard it's very safe if
you hear a gunshot you hear that from
two miles away you know I mean it's loud
everything in the woods hears that with
a bow it's kind of sudden
yeah it's you don't really disrupt
nature which is cool you know like
people say do puzzles and [ __ ] keeps
your brain nice you know for you for me
it's it's stuff like this you know
fire fire open go for broke repeat all
right you go yeah this one [ __ ] looks
out on bud even a caller
Savage
[Music]
well that's not very good it's a turning
point again hot here in the background
you start getting that like oh why we're
doing this waters about it isn't it
water oh my god this isn't the hottest
one so I'm so [ __ ] I have a sensitive
mouth oh I'm not good at this
so you may be a city slicker living in
New York City but it Shawn it's hot you
have you have a heart that it just
wanders in the wilderness you're a bit
of a green thumb as well I know that
you've been gardening a lot lately and
you're kind of having like a Caddyshack
experience with these groundhogs look at
everything they ate everything they hate
my mic my green beans they eat my
zucchini they my eggplant they ate my
pumpkins a my watermelon how are you
trying to solve for this rifle no I'm
just kidding no animals are harmed in my
backyard um I got one of those havahart
cages my dad brought it over and we
caught that little bugger and we dropped
him off in Pennsylvania well now it's
getting more it's Thanksgiving you know
my my garden careful around your eyes
yeah thank you
can't believe this four more to do
yeah they're a problem the skunk's too
now and the squirrels you know it's
getting fall autumn II squirrels are in
there digging holes everywhere putting a
little freaking acorns and [ __ ]
whatever cares
[Music]
ghost Reaper yeah let's see those what
the [ __ ] all right let's eat the aka me
so what are you doing just a straight-up
bite your [ __ ] monster gonna start
swallow [ __ ] like a [ __ ] shark
just bite it and swallow it so you and
the bone Appetit recently dropped a
massive Thanksgiving package where you
guys basically took all of the holiday
classics deconstructed them and then put
them in their best form right what's the
key to deep-frying a bird and not burn
in your whole backyard okay well start
off make sure your bird is not frozen I
know it sounds silly but I think like
once a year someone does that it like
you put it it blows up it's not a good
thing don't ever do it and then having
the right gear don't try to make some
make shifting buy a kit you know it has
the has the lowering thing they just got
the proper pot you don't want a big wide
one you want something tall they can
just fill up and do a displacement
before you go fry and put it in with
water mark a line so you know you don't
go filling it with hot oil put your bird
in and then overflows catches on fire
burn your house down you one's got to go
mac and cheese mashed potatoes who now
has mac and cheese on Thanksgiving
mac and cheese mashed potatoes candied
yams or stuffing one's got to go mac and
cheese that doesn't scream Thanksgiving
best and worst Thanksgiving pies best
and we're I'm a fan I love a pumpkin pie
my whole life I have I just get in
trouble for eating too much of it cold
little slivers you know little ones like
10 or 20 of them little ones to biters
you come back over 15 minutes later you
go back get another one all night
ice-cold whoo I don't want no hot pie
man I don't really like pecan pie
because there's like so much like [ __ ]
like just sugary kind of sticky southern
[ __ ] in there that I'm not a fan of I
like the nuts so for making perfect we
took a pumpkin pie and we put the pecans
best of both worlds right
[Music]
[Music]
gone oh oh that wasn't good either
that was a big bite Sean oh yeah I'm not
sure the whole chunk and swallow
was it good technique oh that's not good
yeah so I want to go record [ __ ] yeah I
want to go on record and say that the
video that you did with our buddy Our
Mutual Friend Matty Matheson where you
guys went to Oklahoma and went noodling
together
it's got to be top five YouTube videos
of the year so now that you're here
who's is lean on dabomb I'd like to get
a director's commentary what does it
really feel like when I'm one of those
catfish feels a lot better eating these
[ __ ] wings sure I want to tell you
that chomps down on your arm
oh well pick my foot oh my god it's so
hot oh you're going milk yeah drink milk
a little milk Oh room temp milk grapes I
seem better my eyes are tearing Sean
yeah Oh yours are two tears of happiness
we go there so hot
yeah so noodling a lot of fun it was a
little beaver hole and I had to go up to
my waist in it
talking hurts more and uh yeah a catfish
bit my foot it didn't feel good it's so
hot in this shirt yeah well I'm not I
can't use this [ __ ] thing no it's
been a contaminated oh [ __ ] not the
shirt yeah I blew my nose Shawna just
who's this
it's horrible how do you do this we're
living
we got a brochure please damn she looks
for any excuse she can to get into the
get into the spotlight and pass off it
will save that horn I'll blow my nose in
this one let's throw it right away I
feel it in my ears
it was horrible
all right look great never better
[ __ ] never better all right firing
forward Shawn all right this one is
called burn after eating yeah yeah oh we
gotta eat it okay well this is so [ __ ]
I'm going small here I don't want to do
this at all yeah really good it's a lot
of fun so Brad your guy who swings
arrows but also knows how to make a
perfect Thanksgiving pie you're the
right mix of every man and gourmand
where does one find better bagels in New
York or New Jersey Montreal oh that
wasn't our option um I'm gonna say New
Jersey New York a lot of bad bagel a lot
of bad bagels in general in the whole
tri-state area it's tough to find a good
one but my dad
it's uncomfortable night Tara my dad
used to be a mailman he used to deliver
mail in Livingston New Jersey careful
around your eyes that's right and there
was this lady who had a bagel shop and
they were fantastic that's all I got
have you gotten into the like CBD oil
infused food and drink at all no I mean
I'm a fan of CBD but like I don't want
it with my meal I just want to like take
it as a committer Center
what's your biggest restaurant pet peeve
like when you walk into a place how
early can you tell this isn't a place
that vibes with Brad Leonean unbalanced
hot sauces you know like just
over-the-top hot sauces you know I got
my man of balance what was the question
[Music]
Brad this is the last step we call it
the last dab because what are you doing
or are you learning more on there so I
put a little extra on the last week you
don't have to if you don't want to I'm
not putting extra you can go [ __ ]
yourself that's terrible all right
cheers bud Cheers
oh my god sure don't do that my [ __ ]
ears hurt sorry Brian know why I bred
here we are at the end of our annual and
reviving special hot ones yeah and if
we've learned anything it is that you
are distinctly Brad we learn many things
you do this show one's the Brad way yeah
at all times
when everyone else screams for Turkey
Brad screams for chicken I don't know
when everyone screams for turkey on
Thanksgiving when everyone screams for
Turkey yeah
Brad screams for joy on Thanksgiving
when everybody screams for Turkey yeah
Brad it doesn't scream for Turkey he
screams for a lobster Lobster ah now
that so today we're closing things out
with a very special Thanksgiving main
event the Brad way the Brad way yeah and
we're not gonna put any hot sauce on it
I promise you okay well uh Thanksgiving
I guess it's a sensitive subject you
know but with the Pilgrims and Native
Americans
you know Massachusetts correct me if I'm
wrong we're gonna fact-check all of that
but um we won't there was lobsters there
was lobster it must have been lobsters
involved I'm not trying to hear that the
first Thanksgiving didn't have lobsters
[ __ ] everywhere should cover them
with obey you throw them in the steamer
we got a nice little basket in here I
don't know I don't know if you guys are
shooting oh sure you are we got a little
cage in there a little basket you know a
little quick easy release boom boom
we'll throw our lobsters in there let
them steam all right ten twelve minutes
oh yeah you delicious creatures and then
look we'll hit them with a little bag or
like a lot oh yeah oh yeah cover a
middle Bay that's the stuff bud are you
kidding me
so I like to lay down a couple good
layers of newspaper here you know
real nice Sean now I've imagined this
alright close your eyes
it's hot outside it's not Thanksgiving
anymore okay
you're sitting out on a picnic table you
got a cold beer all right boom you've
about to drop a whole bunch of lobsters
we will put some work in RIT's are
cracking away we're gonna eat them I'm
gonna start you off with a real treat I
call it the lobster shooter all right so
just pop off yeah there you go pop off a
claw hold this part up this is fantastic
oh you're in for fun oh you don't like
seafood and then you're gonna put this
part in your mouth well I'll do a demo
oh my god it's like shotgunning a beer I
guess but it's a lobster you bring food
on an airplane show yeah [ __ ] imma bring
this Lobster oh my god no you know what
listen I want to take this time here and
Hounds on the Thanksgiving special to
say this I nobody is better to sit next
to on a plane than me I'm so low
maintenance I take a great deal of pride
in my [ __ ] you know flyer right here
I'll eat it I'll eat some trail mix
maybe you just sip some water but on
that bring in the [ __ ] Shake Shack
the whole plate
I'm very polite get out thank you that
you gave me the opportunity to say that
you know that's often splash on the back
on this show the world needs to be a
better place especially in the air you
like Lobster
consider me a convert not really at all
but you know what Brad it was a lot of
fun from the wings to the lobster chaser
and I do want to take this time to say
Happy Thanksgiving to all the spice
Lords out there all the hot ones fans
who have now rocked with us from Rachael
Ray Thanksgiving special to now Bradley
I never run in between man I'm honored
thank you for having me I bow who was on
here before you had that maniac Shia
LeBouf on here something yeah you know
nice guy I didn't mean that in a bad way
to show that you're scary so and
everyone else man I thank you for having
me
this is fantastic this camera this
camera this camera or this camera or
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life oh thank you
yeah so please never really cool I make
some really cool fermentation and
project and where food comes from Travel
Show it's called it's live and it's live
going places it's on YouTube and free
streaming apps with bone Appetit and
find that on your Roku and stuff like
that it's alive its alive going places
Bon Appetit check it out good fun I me a
big old lobster hand [ __ ] oh no sorry
Sean that's a very nice shirt oh my god
and we on actual Thanksgiving I go to my
wife's family that will do this and they
they all they'll get a [ __ ] cake yeah
yeah and they'll be very meta as you
like eat lobster while you watch oh my
god very cool what's up space Lords tis
I camera guy bill you know what they say
about today it's all about the poultry
we're worried about the Christmas tree
next month this Thanksgiving I just
wanted to tell you how thankful I am for
you spice Lords you're the gravy to my
mashed potatoes you're the apple of my
pie because of you I still have a job
and because of you
my hit single xxx particular reached
number one on the Platinum Billboard 100
hot fire songs this Thanksgiving while
you're sitting on the couch stuffed
ignoring your family members scrolling
through your phone why don't you go to
the first three fees page and give us a
nice thankful like and subscribe it
would really mean a lot to me and the
rest of the hot ones family this is
camera guy bill here saying it's good to
be a camera guy bill
[Music]